everybody some humbled by the task of
the responsibility of presenting the
interactions of complexity and
algorithmic game theory to you because
there's having a lot and reach and
beautiful work that has been done and I
had to do some selections so I decided
to split my talk into two parts the
first today talking about equilibria and
solution concepts and the second talking
about mechanisms and that's tomorrow and
you know I'm about to start my first
part and I'm gonna start with a
motivating spiel because this is about
games do you guys know this game it's I
you know the tone is check and I don't
know how it's pronounced bar beats
qivana vanna or something like that so
the game is played as follows so you
know this is a graph there's a start
node and end node and if you see here is
the something cut out of the piece of
paper it used to be a hexagon okay with
one one side per color there are six
colors here so what you do is you cut it
out you put a toothpick in the middle
and you rotate it other tools to select
a random color out of the six colors in
the board okay now the game is played as
follows you put a talk in here and the
next player who moves he spins the wheel
selects a random color and you know if
it's blue for example he can go here
right if the colors not available he has
no moves to do some knows you can select
for example if you here and you get a
green you can select whether you want to
go here or there all right and people
alternate moves okay now one player one
players goal is to maximize the
probability the talking ends up here the
other player wants to minimize the
probability all right and since the
probability sums to one is basically a
constant sum game alright so in you know
basically zero
game the game ends if the talking ends
up here that's when the game ends so
that will be my next question right what
is the who wins and the player who wants
to get here always wins okay see it's a
little argument you have to do okay
now this game there's a special case of
class of games called simple stochastic
games introduced by che play in the 50s
these are plainly played in a graph the
note of the graph are split into player
ones the blue player two's that's the
red player and nature's brown and there
is a special start note that belongs to
somebody and you know the game starts
with a token here now this is a
directive graph and it has at least one
sink the sink nodes are either the blue
players I belong to that the blue player
of the red player and the game is played
does follow so there is a talk and if
the talking belongs to the blue player
he decides which edge to follow next if
it's my red players note he decides if
it's on the nature is nodes nature
pushes are talking randomly for instance
if the token is here nature will
randomly push it to to this this or that
node now these are called simple
stochastic games and here are some facts
about them first there exists optimal
memoryless strategies meaning that you
know if the you know if the blue player
has some optimal strategy the first time
the talking arrives here if the talking
arrives to this node again his strategy
would be the same right so it's memory
less you don't care about how the token
has traveled you know there is there is
enough there are optimal memoryless
strategies okay
so because of that you can solve it you
know using the min/max theorem you can
write an LP and find the optimal
strategy for the for each of the players
so from a game theoretic perspective
this is a very nice class of games they
are solvable by min max and in this case
actually the values to have well-defined
values and in this case the values of
two-thirds and one-third why because
basically okay if the token is here the
RET player would just push it to his
sync and the game is over
this guy definitely won't push it here
he prefers to go down now he has now
this is post randomly with probability
2/3
gets on the cycle if it's pushed here he
you know the red player wins okay so
that's the value of the game and the but
the problem which makes the game the
analysis of this games hard is that the
blue player has an exponential number of
strategies in his nodes and so does the
red player right because the blue player
strategy consists of what he's going to
do for each of the nodes that belong to
him all right so the number of
strategies pure strategies available to
each player scales exponentially with
the number of nodes under his control so
if I were to approach this game as a
zero-sum game like as a normal form game
I would have to have variables under the
scale exponentially with the number of
nodes so this is not practical to solve
these games and in fact we don't know
how to solve them in general in
polynomial time
except for instance if the graph is a
tree in that case classical results of
color megiddo from Senka allow you to
solve these games again so there's no
computationally efficient algorithm for
these games and despite them being Big
Mac solvable which is one of their best
the sharpest solution concepts in game
theory despite that fact
the lack of a polynomial time algorithm
for finding mimic strategies makes it
doubtful that players always discover
mimic strategies as I said kid threes
are solvable so that means that min max
is much more likely to be seen in
practice and you know if you want to
learn more about you know this the use
of min max in large tree structure games
and watch it to come to our ADT and
practice workshop where I believe Thomas
unhung will talk about to play Texas
Holdem the events of the perspective of
this lecture is that even widely
accepted solution concepts such as min
max may be may suffer from computational
intractability
this makes the analyst unable to compute
this solution concepts but also it makes
it doubtful that they always actually
happen in practice and I always like to
say this code of kemal Jane that if your
laptop cannot find an equilibrium then
chances are the market is not also able
to discover that equilibrium so the
perspective I'm going to have in this
lecture is I'm going to look at you know
equilibria and other solution concepts
from a computational point of view so
that was the motivation part of the talk
let's go one step back and consider the
simplest type of game which which are
called normal form games these are
described by explicitly stating the
strategies of every player as well as
the payoff of every player for each
selection of strategies usually
summarized in a table like this one so
if the 20s for Norman showed that any
two-player game of this form if it's
zero-sum meaning that for every
combination of strategies the sum of the
payoffs of the players is zero that
every every game like that has an
equilibrium and in fact it's min max
solvable it's a very strong type of
solution concepts it's a unique basic
and equilibrium
computed with linear programming if the
game is more general we know the
classical result of Nash that it does
that the equilibrium still exists it may
not be unique and we don't know how to
solve it prob efficiently so in fact let
me compare these two theorems because
the point a nice that they have a very
nice tight relation that the weight is
at some point so here the two theorems
so for moments proof actually originally
you know when he proved this theorem
there was non linear programming so he
used analysis to establish the result
but when Danzig was developing the
linear programming theory they realized
together that this strong LP duality
actually implies this theorem in fact in
LAN Adler faculty at are here very
recently proved that the implication
goes in the other direction as well
namely min max implies also strong LP
duality that was just recently proven
relevant so because we have polynomial
time algorithms for linear programs we
actually know how to compute these
solution concepts and you know a long
line of research starting at what do was
starting fictitious play has provided
the you know and going to no regret
algorithms and so on so forth has
provided multitude of distributed
dynamics that actually get to min max
equilibria so this is a very well
understood solution concept one that is
likely to are to arise in practice it's
easily computable and you know so as an
indication of that you know again I
invite you to dinner to to come and hear
some of you know the New Age
applications of the minimax in solving
large two player zero-sum games on this
side of general games again you know
Nash uses you know topological last
theorems to prove his result and
following you still and there's been a
lot of
work trying to find polynomial time
algorithms in fact some of them are very
suspiciously the suspiciously similar to
you know to the simplex method but but
despite that research that we have we
have no efficient algorithm for this
problem and of course then no dynamics
and sort of like you know a computer
scientist in front of sort of like this
sort of like type of progress thinks to
himself oh is it taking complete to find
a Nash equilibrium given that people
have tried and failed to find one and
okay sorry it's you know so I have sort
of like I'm going to do a poor job in
defining NP completeness okay simply
complete is the standard theory the
standard framework computational
framework to talk about complexity of
problems starting with cook and carb and
we know very rich theory after them and
pick up elitist basically means that
your problem is equivalent to the
boolean satisfiability problem I'm not
going to define it but here's the
definition if now she's np-complete what
this means is that there are no
general-purpose
algorithms for finding Nash equilibria
so we cannot compute them efficiently so
we cannot predict player behavior in
every game but worse still is that the
universality promised by nauseous
theorem basically breaks down if if the
best algorithmic machinery cannot find
Nash equilibria then how likely is it
that players always discover them okay
so the universality problems by Nasus
theorem breaks down from a computational
point of view
so in fact the potential Olympic elitist
of Nash equilibrium was has been
investigated but MP does not seem to be
the right complexity class to capture
this problem and basically the reason is
that Nash's theorem guarantees that the
Nash equilibrium exists and any attempt
to try to prevent the completeness of
Nass basically leads to other
implications for complexity theory that
are not likely
so in fact and a Nash equilibrium is
believed to lie somewhere between P and
NP complete problems okay and I'm sort
of like you know for for the next few
minutes I'll try to sort of like
navigate you through how you go about
trying to understand the Nash equilibria
the complexity of Nash equilibrium okay
so it makes a nice and methodological
story if you want so you know we have a
problem that whose complexity we don't
understand and you know we've tried to
solve it to find efficient algorithms we
have failed on the other hand we've
tried to prove complexity results we
have also failed so what do we look for
you know where do we look to try to
classify this problem into some
complexity class and you know what what
crystals did in the 90s is to basically
look at Nash's proof and try to
understand you know behind all
mathematical office keishon right that
has to do with topology what is what
what part of this proof cannot be
simulated computationally okay at the
end of the day Nasus theorem is an
existence theorem so it proves that
something exists
it basically constructs that object the
question is what in this construction
breaks down if you try to simulate it
computationally okay so you know you go
back to the proof and so forth trying to
understand what what is that step in the
proof that you cannot simulate
efficiently you know it turns out that
you know if you remove all application
there is a very easy parity lemma that
actually lies in the
part of the proof you should all be
familiar with this if I give you a
directed graph and an unbalanced vertex
in that graph then there must be another
unbalanced vertex you cannot have an odd
number or fun but you know you don't
have just one unbalanced vertex in it so
that's really I claim that sort of like
behind all this you know behind the
proof really the existence theorem is
this and and and sort of like to give
you a hint of how this parity argument
arises in the proof of Nash let me talk
about a related problem in topological
sperner's lemma so for that I'm gonna
consider this square which I have
triangulated and I'm going to consider a
coloring of the nodes of this graph what
I'm going to assume is that the boundary
has the coloring shown in the picture
okay but I'm gonna allow you to color
the internal vertices in whatever way
you want using the three colors the
claim of the lemma is that no matter how
you color the nodes they exist a thick
chromatic triangle and in fact there is
an odd number of them so can you spot
them in their picture there are five
so what I'm going to do is I'm going to
try to prove you this theorem and and
hopefully during the proof you'll see
how the parity argument arises naturally
so I'm forgetting about the existence of
these triangles okay and I'm agnostic as
to whether they exist and I'm going to
try to prove this lemma now I'm going to
imagine that this is a big factory
partitioned into triangular domes in
fact Krista's told me that scarf he
calls this the Lemke house okay so okay
so this is a firm it's a factory
partition in triangular rooms and I'm
gonna do a work I'm gonna start working
in this Factory and my walk is going to
start at the bottom left triangle now
notice that the three pillars of this
room all touch the boundary and by
assumption there's no doubt as to what
the three colors are okay no matter how
you cover the internal vertices I know
that the three pillars of the room have
the specific colors now my walk is gonna
try crossing doors in the following way
so I'm going to cross a door if it's red
yellow and I can cross it leaving the
room having yell on my left okay so this
room has two red yellow doors this one
and that one this one if I cross it
yellows on my right so don't like it I'm
not gonna cross it but this one if I
cross to have yellow on my left and
direction is important so I'm going to
only cross red yellow doors from now on
if I can cross them having yellow on my
left so I'm gonna get to this triangle
now there is a question right if this
you know if this was a blue I would be
done but it's not so it's a yellow but
that opens up another red yellow door I
can cross with yellow in my left so this
is what I'm going to do so I'm going to
cross that door get into another room
and so forth and if you follow that work
it takes you to a tri-chromatic triangle
now I claim that this was not accidental
that I go to a tri-chromatic triangle
and to convince you about that I'm going
to first say that my work cannot escape
the factory
the reason my work will never exit the
factory is that if you look at all the
doors on the boundary there is no red
yellow door there's only one at the
yellow door but you cannot cross it
leaving the factory
all right so definitely the work is not
going to exit the factory so the the
work is not exit to the factory and
there is a finite number of rooms all
right so the other thing that can happen
let's talk about the possible stopping
condition for my my walk right so the
stopping condition for my work is that I
just from that square up here and then
go straight up right then you're always
crossing with yellow and you're right
you have to has to be ready even if you
get me here it's not a red yellow door
so how if even if you got there you
cannot exit now let's think about the
possible stopping condition for my walk
right so my walk always enters into a
room through a red yellow door okay if
you find the blue there you're done
you're gonna stop that's good okay you
found a trick chromatic triangle you
entered through a red yellow door you
found the blue you're done if you don't
find it blue you the see a red or a
yellow if you think about it there's
another door you can cross in that case
right if it's a red you go this way this
way if the yellow you go this way okay
so I definitely won't stop unless I find
a tri-chromatic triangle now what's the
other bad case okay so I cannot exit the
only way to stop is to find a
tri-chromatic triangle what's the other
possibility so I can sort of likes to
wander a little bit and then get into a
loop that's wonder again into a loop now
the loop definitely doesn't close here
because to close here it has to get in
here from the outside so it has to be a
row shape but if it's a row shape you
need the room where they are all
connects to itself right when the loop
connects to the bar
the wrong shape you need a room with
three red yellow doors and that cannot
happen okay
so if there is right so if if my walks
are like you know start here and wanders
a little bit and that gets into this row
shape then over here you need you need a
room that oops with a room with three
red yellow doors right so one that you
first used and exit and then exit it and
then the one you come back yeah there
has to be there are blue dots on the
boundary I did use it if there weren't
blue doors on the boundary that would be
a yellow red yellow door that would take
me outside right so I use the boundary
condition yeah so that's the proof right
so I can the only way to stop is to find
a tri-chromatic triangle
I cannot exit I cannot get into a loop
so that's the end of the proof but there
is one triangle any questions about that
good so now actually let me even even
show you that there is an odd number of
them and for that I'm gonna sort of like
fictitiously land into an arbitrary
triangle in this factory it happened to
be one that has a red yellow door which
I can cross with yellow in my left let
me just do that okay let me keep
crossing doors having yellow red yellow
doors having yellow on my left that took
me over here that's that's cool let me
go back here let go let me go backwards
okay so let me go backwards having
yellow on my left to maintain my
condition that all right so I'm going
backwards to put to another trick a
lotty triangle that looks really cool
right so you know let me do this
experiment from its starting from any
triangle that has
been visited yet so let me for example
know so start here I'll get this to guys
oh you know if I start over here I'm
gonna actually get into a loop and
that's okay over here I can close a loop
over there my argument earlier is that I
couldn't come close the loop involving
this triangle because that would involve
coming from the outside which I cannot
get to so basically I can do this
experiment right that I can start from
any triangle if it has a red yellow door
I can cross it in the right direction so
these are isolated rooms
I cannot go anywhere if I start here but
otherwise I have covered my my factory
with paths and cycles so let me let me
just you know obstruct away what's
happening here in this argument right so
really the only thing I defined is a
transition condition that says if you
find a red yellow door between two
adjacent rooms across it having yellow
on your left this is the only thing I
did in this proof right but just this
mere fact that I defined this transition
rule between rooms allowed me to first
of all start from the bottom left angle
and follow it getting to a definitely a
tri-chromatic triangle well otherwise
covering the space of triangles with
other paths directed paths both of whose
endpoints are tri-chromatic triangle
isolated vertices and loops that's what
the parity argument actually comes in
but in effect what I did is I defined a
directed graph that had a special
triangle but that basically defined the
directed graph are comprised of directed
paths isolated vertices and directed
cycles all the endpoints of directed
paths were solutions except for the path
that starts at the special bottom left
triangle right so all solutions basic
much to each other through a path that
connects them except the solution
starting at the bottom left so there has
to be an odd number of solutions and
that's the end of the proof so hopefully
after this argument it makes sense that
it makes sense that I use the parity
argument I promise that in effect what I
did is I created a directed graph and I
gave you an unbalanced vertex of the
graph that's the definition of the graph
there has to be another unbalanced
vertex and that unbalanced vertex by the
definition of the graph has to be
trichromatic because if it weren't it
wouldn't be an endpoint you have been
balanced so that's where the part of the
argument comes into all these proofs and
and and green stuff in the ninth is
looking at all these proofs decided to
define a complexity class which you can
do formally but I'm not going to do here
a complexity class containing all
problems that have a guaranteed solution
because of this specific parity argument
okay there is a formal way to do that
but you can define a class of
computational problems that always have
solutions and the reason they have
solutions is this parity argument these
problems basically induce directed graph
and they also give you an unbalanced
vertex of that graph and they ask you to
find another unbalanced vertex now if
you took an algorithms class you would
think that this problem is trivial
because you know all of you know your
first class in algorithms is about graph
problems and this sounds definitely
sounds like a trivial problem you can
solve okay you can just inspect all the
nodes of the graph and find the other
unbalanced vertex so what what so what's
the point of this class then
the point is that sometimes and as it so
happens for the interesting problems the
graph that's induced by the problem is
actually exponentially large it's and
here's here's an example problem right
so suppose my square is exponentially
large okay and instead of listing
explicitly the color of every vertex
instead I give you a circuit that X has
input the coordinates of a point which
can be succinctly described using n bits
and spits out the color of that vertex
and I give you the circuit I'll give you
all the gates all the other mechanics
inside the circuit you can see the
circuit and using the circuit you can
query the color of every vertex of this
sixth or otherwise exponentially large
square alright and the question is by
looking at the description of the
circuit are you able to locate a
tri-chromatic triangle so that's the
point of the theorem this problem is not
easy to solve okay because really you
have to understand what the sector is
doing to be able to predict where the
tri-chromatic triangle is of course you
could just do the algorithm that I told
you right so you could start over here
and do a lazy evaluation of the nodes
that you need to evaluate as your work
progresses but in the worst case your
work could go all over the place and
basically just cover the whole square in
the worst case this is going to be an
exponentially long path and this is why
the problem is difficult right so these
problems in people you did use an
exponentially large graph and that's why
it's hard to you know by inspection find
the other unbalanced vertex and so p-pod
as far as we know lies somewhere between
P N and P complete now the prints ylides
argue that the sperner problem is in PPD
because it is proven by parity argument
and if you and there are proofs of
browses theorem that use partners
theorem so
for that reason Brauer is also in the
class but really that's not the point of
the definition of the class the litmus
test for whether this class is
successful at capturing problems that
are of interest is whether you can prove
completeness results completeness is out
to tell you that not all would tell you
that not all these problems are in this
class but they are exactly as heart of
this class and exactly as how there's
any other problem in this class and this
actually has been done successfully by
christos and this paranoid problem in
two dimensions by children during
recently okay so not only Peapod
contains these problems but exactly
characterizes the complexity of those
problems any other problem this class is
as hard as these problems okay so that
this was the point of the definition of
this class okay so you start so right so
so so what is ingenious it is that you
start by underserving there are a lot of
problems in topology and combinatorics
are proven via parity argument you turn
that argument into a class and then you
hope that the class that comes out of
this is actually not bigger than this
problem but exactly tightly
characterizes these problems yeah that
was the point of the definition
right so this is the picture and because
Nash is proven via browser serum and
Brower is proven the burner
we know that Nass is definitely
contained in this class and the question
that arises is whether it's in between
are also exactly equal to the other
problems and you know I'm gonna cut the
chase and tell you that basically Nass
is also people complete so this class
Peapod not only contains this
topological and combinatorial probes but
also exactly captures the complexity of
Nash equilibria and in fact even for
two-player games all right there's a
clear dichotomy so two player zero-sum
games are efficiently solvable using
linear programming two-player
nonzero-sum games are p-pod complete so
they're exactly as hard as brower's
burner and any other problem in this
complexity class it was interesting to
hear ro saying that he was inspired by
Nash when he proved the error the birth
theorem Peapod is not sort of like this
results are not a singular phenomenon a
lot of solution concepts in economics
are actually people complete and the
reason is that basically a lot of this
existence is out used apology so it was
shown that finding out of the break
Calibri ax is also people complete the
ref it has been a lot of other work
showing that you know these are at the
other game or solution concept is people
are complete so Peapod is the class you
know sort of like the natural class for
solution concepts
okay so and sort of like when we prove
those results this code of Vaman came to
mind okay that two player zero-sum games
are one of the few areas in game theory
and it did the social sciences where a
fairly sharp unique prediction is made
now when we know you know when we prove
this result I understood what he meant
so I think what he meant is that
equilibria of zero-sum games are
efficiently computable they're a convex
set and they can be reached by
distributed dynamics efficiently well
you know outside of these games things
are difficult equilibria are
disconnected Peapod completes not
reachable by dynamics in general and
then this is what I thought right what
does it say about a game theory
prediction and I thought that you know
that's not you know what this says is
that do you know it says that you cannot
hope to do things in a very very general
way if you want to predict behavior but
and what I want to discuss now is
possible escapes from the interact
ability result and I'm going to discuss
a few so the first one which was
basically covered by christos is looking
at approximation so Nash equilibria
require that players do not have
incentives to deviate from to deviate
from their current Authority
so maybe Nash equilibriums how to
compute exactly but many approximate
versions are easy to compute so it could
be that you know no player has more than
some small epsilon incentive to change
there's his strategy given what the
others are doing how about the
complexity of this problem now there's a
question of what I mean by this sentence
traditionally in computer science we
look at the relative approximations
while it's more customary in economics
starting this karf to look at absolute
errors so let me discuss the two
versions what we know about the two
versions of the problem so this
standard the computer science notion of
approximation turns out to be a dead end
okay so for some epsilon think of point
zero one two-player games
finding a pair of mixed strategies so
that no player can improve by more than
one percent fraction his current payoff
is as hard as finding an exact
equilibrium okay so this standard notion
approximation is just a dead end as I
said starting with scarf and this is
more relevant for fixed point
computation because it's hard to define
what it means to have a relative
approximation for a fixed point I mean
it's not as natural at least starting
with some very beautiful work of
Lichtenberg action vector we know that
probably the problem of finding an
additive epsilon Nash equilibrium is not
going to be people complete because
these guys provide an algorithm that
finds an epsilon Nash from a two-player
and strategy game in time that's quasi
polynomials it's n to the log and so
this is very far from being exponential
it's a big open problem whether this is
tight or it can't be proved
there has been a lot of work trying to
get a polynomial time algorithms but it
has been stuck for about I don't know
eight years and it's a great open
problem to see and you know if there was
some progress on this problem during the
semester I would be thrilled
so as christos discussed yesterday they
conjectured that this is tight but I'm
not sure I agree with them okay so
that's a greater problem right so escape
number two from interact abilities to
actually look at games with special
structure right so arbitrary normal from
games are hard but we know that two
player zero-sum games are easy and that
has been proven in practice right again
as I said we can solve very hard large
two player zero-sum games like poker
efficiently
so the goal here is to identify you know
question yes
I wouldn't leak the word speciality
economics there's virtually no games
with a great number of actions that lack
structure so for us to pathological case
is a million completely unrelated
actions so the word special is maybe too
critical I would lobby for a more
neutral or positive word games you know
the natural structure or something yeah
so let's not sorry us having some
structure makes a lot of sense right
yeah for me too right so in some sense
but people are completely result says
look you cannot be arbitrary you cannot
look at arbitrary games but it opens the
door to actually understanding what is
that structure that enables efficient
computation and makes equilibria are
more likely to arise and what possible
structures are actually bad for
equilibrium so yeah exactly that's the
goal here right so so whenever a game of
interest has this special structure this
good structure if you want we can be
more confident on our predictions that
you can actually find them and also when
designing a game maybe if we understand
both structures enable equilibria to
action arise we can actually use it also
as a design principle
okay so introduce that structure in our
game to be able to you know to be more
confident that actual equilibria will
arise and it's not going to be a mess
where we have no prediction of what's
happening I'm going to give two examples
in this vein multiplayer zero-sum games
and anonymous games where this has been
successful
starting with multiplayer zero-sum games
and your first complaint with
multiplayer zero-sum games would be the
following that you know take an
arbitrary two-player game introduce a
third player who decides of his payoff
is minus the sum of the other guys so
that's a flip player zero-sum game but
it can't be easier than the two-player
game you started with and that we know
is a Peapod complete so what the heck
you know how can zero sum
help me so notice that the payoff of you
know this third player is is a function
of the strategies of both the other two
players combined so this game involves
three-way interactions the question that
arises what if only pairwise
interactions are allowed okay that's a
model called polymatrix games that are
played on a graph the graph can be
arbitrary the nodes of this graph are
players every edge of the game is a
two-player game and the nodes basically
some their paths are separable so to
decide his payoff Hugh sums the path he
gets from all the adjacent edges and you
know this quadratic form expresses his
expected payoff from one edge then you
sum your edges over here some your pairs
over edges now for completely arbitrary
games
it's Peapod complete to solve this class
of games but what if the global game is
zero-sum what do you have if you want a
closed system where you know for every
you know always the total sum of payoffs
is zero or a constant what happens in
that case so for that class we have very
positive results we know that in this
zero-sum polymatrix games a Nash
equilibrium can be found efficiently
with linear programming equilibria are a
convex set and if every node uses an
aura great learning algorithm then the
global behavior converges to a Nash
equilibrium so a particular several of
the good properties of zero-sum games
are inherited in this model so that's an
example of a success in understanding
what structures allow equilibria to
arise efficiently for my other example
anonymous games I'm gonna talk a little
bit about what what also Tim mentioned
in his introduction
these are these are games where every
player may be different but importantly
his payoff only depends on the aggregate
behavior of the other players so you
should think of auctions traffic you
know some social phenomena of this
structure have this property so for
these games we know that arbitrarily
good approximations cannot be computed
in polynomial time as long as the number
of studies doesn't scale but the number
of players can scale while exactly
equilibria are intractable okay so there
people complete looking at these games
has enabled very interesting wasn't so
finding these algorithms was enabled by
actually proving some results about a
probability theory specifically some
central limit theorems and which are
beautiful and have consequences outside
of game theory which I really like let
me give you an example so here's an
example theorem that is useful in
getting those algorithms so for all
epsilon and then let's look at the sum
of independent Bernoulli zero one one
random variables okay so that's a
discrete distribution of support n plus
one that's unimodal it's also you know
concave actually and you know like we
have some idea about how it behaves
right so if the expectations of this
Bernoulli's are buried away from zero
and one then as n goes to infinity the
behavior of this object convert it looks
the distribution of the subject looks
like a Gaussian in some other regimes
when the expectations are not running
away from zero and one it may look like
a possum so we have some idea about how
this object looks so what we show is
we'll show the following dichotomy
result so any such sum of independent
random variables may exhibit one of two
possible behaviors that are both very
you know what you know both you know
well-behaved
so it's either close to a sum of iid
Bernoulli's okay this could be arbitrary
okay but any such object is either close
to the sum of iid Bernoulli's or the sum
of 1 over epsilon cubed Bernoulli's plus
a constant right so whatever accuracy
you want in the approximation you would
paid here we have a large end number of
Bernoulli's and you're interested in a
particular approximation epsilon well
you can give you the following either
you're some looks like a binomial or the
Bernoulli's are the same or a sparse
distribution where only 1 over epsilon
cubed Bernoulli's are involved plus a
shift the monistic shift so we get you
know interesting limit theorems like
this one as a tool to get those
algorithms so in the just to give you a
sense of what's happening what this
theorem implies in the game theoretic
setting is the following that in every
end player to start the anonymous game
there has to be an epsilon Nash
equilibrium where either all the players
who randomized and that's the first case
use the same mixed strategy or at most
one over epsilon cubed players
randomized and this correspond to the
two cases of the theorem right so what
we show is that in any anonymous game
you can find an epsilon Nash equilibria
either everybody who's randomizing uses
the same Xterra T or at most a small
number of people randomize and that
should remind you something in the paper
of Nash from the brown paper the second
paper where he analyzes symmetric games
and he proves that in a symmetric game
which is a smaller class than this there
exists a Nash equilibrium where
everybody used the same mixed strategy
ok if you want this theorem generalizes
that theorem by using approximation and
proving this
kotomi result okay so either you have
very few people randomizing or everybody
who's randomizing is the same so we have
extensions of this theorem it's sort of
like a long discussion but if these are
just say say you have a sum of integer
and the variables we have a limit
theorem of similar flavor except now it
depends on what distance you want to
approximate with this is a very tight
this is a very strong notion of distance
so you have to be very careful about the
structure so if you wanna approximate in
l1 which is as I said a strong distance
what you have to be careful about is the
potential mode structure that may arise
just to give you a sense take two times
the binomial so take take a sum of iid
variables bernoulli's x - that's a
binomial but - spread out on the even
numbers now add to that a Bernoulli
that's one-third two-thirds what you did
is you created a binomial you spread it
out and then you interleave it with
another binomial that's kind of like
house I don't know half the weight or
something like half the height so you
get you know you're very far from
unimodality low concavity any of the
other good properties right so we have a
limit theorem that actually can
accommodate that but and respect is mod
structure that arises but it's a bit
more technical - just like yeah so this
is three minutes yeah but we do have
results and if you want to look at multi
strategy anonymous games you have to go
beyond single dimensional on the
variables to multi-dimensional random
variables and you can prove similar
theorems except again
multidimensionality becomes a bit harder
to handle but we have all these results
and we leverage them for these games
everyone is the right distance so that
replacing sort of like if you want a
pure mixed strategy profile that's a
Nash equilibrium with the approximating
one is not going to screw up the payoffs
of the players a lot that's that I
that's that's the right distance if your
game is arbitrary if your utility
functions have some Lipsitz ness you may
be able to look at the weaker distance
and get better algorithms faster
algorithms so you start with the Nash
equilibrium this is a vector of mixed
strategies you replace it with another
vector of mixed strategies what you want
is that the lawson utility that player
suffers if he evaluates his utility with
respect to the new vector of random
variables is close to this other vector
to that utility and and showing it a
total variation or l1 bound suffices to
bound this yeah we're saying something
sorry we're saying that this is close to
that all we need is that this
expectation is close to that expectation
and that's just one way to get it yes
on the end of a slug it implies to
strategy games so if you had a three
strategy game so the three strategy game
is very recent to have to think about it
you know so I believe I believe okay so
without having thought about it for like
ten seconds or three seconds or whatever
I think what happens in three strategy
games is that you have poly one over
epsilon number of players who play their
own mixed strategies and a large number
of players who play the same mixology
but you cannot prove the dichotomy in
the multi dimensional case you cannot
say either everybody plays the same or
very few randomize you have a mixed
state where most of the people play the
same thing and and a small number of
people do their own stuff okay so that's
that's anonymous but there's a very
interesting my last escape in the next
five five minutes is looking at
alternative solution concepts right so
as almost said you know why should we
care about nationalism let's look at
other solution concepts specifically if
Nash equilibrium is intractable there
are two canonical and plausible
alternatives to Nash equilibria and in
fact they're interrelated and this
relation makes at least the first one
plausible are correlated equilibria and
no regret learning behavior okay so
corollary libram generalizes not
indestructible I'm going to talk about
this a little bit
Noora great learning has a very natural
interpretation as an online optimization
as a strategy to be used in an online
optimization setting and thereby is also
very plausible as a player behavior they
also related to corollary equilibrium
it's
not regret learning converges in a
precise sense to what is called the
course correlated equilibrium Tim talked
about crystals about these concepts in
his talk I want to dwell just a little
bit on what changes once you go to
correlate at equilibrium
so I've gotta give the definition but
basically it's a very similar solution
concept to Nash except that you allow
players to to correlate their mixed
strategies okay so now you have a joint
strategy over pure study profiles people
do not sample their strategies
independently and subject to that no
player has incentive to deviate now if
you look at the equilibrium conditions
you'll realize very fast that they can
be expressed as linear constraints in
particular you can set up a linear
program to compute a correlated Calibri
where in fact establish that one exists
now in normal forme games where again
all the payoffs are given and studies
are given explicitly in the description
of the game the resulting LP has
polynomial size the reason is that the
correlate equilibrium needs one variable
to find a probability for every pair for
every you know pure strategy profile but
the description of the game itself also
maintains the same number of payoff
entries so the LP has basically linear
size in the description of the game
which puts the computing a corollary
Calibri own problem in P whereas the
Nash equilibria long loss I said is
Peapod complete but there is much more
to this story and to illustrate that
this were like a trivial observation but
to illustrate how you know how
interesting computationally correlated
libram is let me go back to this
polymatrix games that i mentioned
earlier when I was discussing games with
special structure where I argued that if
there's zero sum an equilibrium can be
computed efficiently using linear
programming
so now in this games if you want to find
the coral at equilibrium you're
basically in trouble okay let's do some
counting to describe the game of this
form you have to specify a two-player
game for every edge there are edges say
every node has s strategies to describe
an entry for every edge for a payoff
table for every edge you need
escort numbers you need to two tables
one for each player you need two times
and to your images to pay of tables per
edge esker entries per table so this is
a description complexity on the other
hand if you want to find the corollary
Librium the object you're trying to
compute is a joint probability
distribution over every player's
strategy the object is huge okay the
size of the object is as the number of
pure actions per node to the power n the
number of nodes which you know far
exceeds the description complexity of
the game so the size of the corollary
the object that you're trying to compute
is exponentially larger than the
description of the game so it looks like
the problem is hopeless
all right so you're trying to compute
something that exponentially larger than
your input so it seems hopeless
vacuous everything's in equilibrium so
it's a big set this very City compute
yes but I mean not like sort of like how
how can I hope to even speed out Joint
Distribution unless I prove that it is
sparse distributions of the support it's
not the coral equilibrium but I'm saying
that the set you're optimizing over the
set of joint probability distributions
is has members that have larger
description complexity
okay now the punchline is that despite
that sort of like apparent interact
ability you can actually find
correlating Lybia that have descriptions
that have polynomial size in the size of
the game okay that's the punchline and
the reason why this is interesting is it
looks hopeless but you can exploit the
fact that the number of equilibrium
constraints are polynomially many and
you can exploit the ellipsoid machinery
to to make that statement so this is a
very interesting example where
computational machinery allows you to
bypass some you know obvious sort of
like bounds lower bounds or apparent
lower bounds now this is very general it
extends to a lot of games so corollary
Calibri are you can think of them as
good objects and so efficiently
computable objects so the summary for
the first part of part of my talk is
that equilibrium may be computationally
tractable and the you know usually the
right class is Peapod there is a
parallel story that I skipped and that
has to do with potential games yes
Oh joint distributions it is a I believe
and Tim should know better
it's sort of like a lower like the
tensor it's a low rank tensor right it
doesn't make sense sorry
as far as tensor you can yes you can
have poly no believable yes
so you can do two versions you can you
can do either as part of tensor or a
distribution with a very special support
depending on which of these two papers
you read right so again I said there's a
parallel story that has to do with
potential games and pure Nash equilibria
and there is a relevant complexity class
capturing those games
now when equilibria are intractable as I
said they're usually result is
questionable because you cannot hope
that players always discover them and
you cannot count on finding them
yourself but you know as drew said so
and I said it's important to understand
what structure of our games if you want
of practical games or games you
otherwise in practice what is that
spatial structure that may enable
equilibria to be efficiently computable
and I give two examples but there are
several others and as I said it's
important to understand you know when
Nash equilibria failed what other
solution concepts are plausible
I want to someone I want to end with you
know sort of like saying that
investigating the complex of equilibria
has provided complexity theory with very
interesting challenging problems and it
hadn't reached complexity theory in its
effort to classify those problems
and without I want to thank you so as I
said tomorrow I'm giving a description
of interaction of complexity and
mechanism design and this is sort of
like stuff I'm going to talk about any
questions